thank you
in the land of Asia welcome to Feathered
Friends In Flight my name is Corey and
I'm Katie all right Logan are you ready
okay here we go you got this
Logan The Raven gets ready for his big
performance
he comes out just the opening of the
show oh
and he finds a water bottle that was
accidentally left on the stage
[Music]
good job he's going straight to the can
and he brings it over to the recycle bin
puts it in the bin recycles it yes he
got it good and that starts the show
[Music]
you did so good good job Logan
you're so good
we really like to feature natural
behaviors of birds and hopefully Inspire
the audience for caring conservation
action they can see birds from all over
the world
[Music]
Logan definitely thinks he's the star of
the show
um you can tell he's extremely handsome
and he always gets really great
reactions from the crowd
they're so smart they've done some
research that shows that Ravens actually
plan for the future they're really good
at problem solving and Tool use which is
pretty amazing
[Music]
Logan's intelligence keeps the team on
their toes we just need a little more
depth in this routine Logan's always
hungry for a challenge so they've come
up with a new one he's going to learn
how to untie knots starting with trainer
Corey shoelaces he's never done anything
with shoes yet no okay it's a really fun
Behavior with a really smart bird who I
think is going to get this pretty quick
but you never know every bird is an
individual so we'll have to see how
Logan does
all right here comes Logan
[Music]
okay I'm gonna spin them around here
just set them down on the ground ready
okay
[Music]
this is a fun puzzle you give them a
puzzle and they figure it out
immediately
[Music]
good that one's great Logan Nails it
without breaking a sweat thanks to a
familiar technique
Katie's saying good he knows that good
word has been paired with food so that
he can know he did the right thing and
if he comes back to Katie he's going to
get a treat
[Music]
good the way you feel that when you
learn something new and you're like I
just did that thing wow how cool was
that I did such a good job that the
birds must have that same feeling
out in the wild they got to use their
intelligence there are crows that have
been seen dropping things like nuts with
a really strong shell onto crosswalks so
that the cars will break them open for
them so they're very very smart it's how
they go through their entire world he
did awesome that was really good
that first training session couldn't
have gone better it was like he had been
doing this his whole life already but it
doesn't just stop at the shoelace there
is a second part to this Behavior it's
pretty complex I hope Logan's ready
[Music]